[Music]
20-18 has been a huge year for
blockbusters with three monster owners
grossing more than a billion bucks of
the worldwide box office 2019 is shaping
up to be just as massive with more
gigantic movies on the way there's more
Star Wars more Avengers and even more
evil demon clowns but that's just
scratching the surface here are the most
hotly anticipated movies of 2019
Hellboy David Harper unveils his new
take on Hellboy on January 11th with the
stranger things start joining director
Neil Marshall for a grittier take on the
Horned half-demon fans should expect a
darker tone than Guillermo del Toro's
take on Hellboy with more of a focus on
the characters inner struggles rather
than fighting giant gear monsters with a
big gun while harbours take on Hellboy
looks spot-on the rest of the cast
doesn't disappoint either including Mila
Jovovich as a villainous Blood Queen and
Ian McShane as hell boys adopted father
a role he has some experience with all
great men have mustaches
Captain Marvel Marvel's first female led
superhero saga will be long overdue
when ahead censors on March 8th but the
movie is shaping up to be worth the wait
Captain Marvel has Academy Award winner
brie Larson as Carol Danvers and Marvel
promises she'll be as powerful a
character as they've ever put in a movie
that means she's strong how strong is
she so so strong she can move planets
there's also some impressive talent
behind the scenes with writers behind
the Tomb Raider reboot guardians of the
galaxy and even inside out or lending a
hand to bring Captain Marvel to life
spider-man far from home Tom Hollands
spider-man is set to continue his
adventures in a second standalone film
out July 8th spider-man homecoming was
super successful with both critics and
fans and the follow-up is a messin with
Marvel's winning formula director John
watts is back to helm the web-slinger's
next adventure and you can expect most
of homecomings excellent cast to make a
return we don't know much about the plot
so far from home but we do know
spider-man will face off against
Mysterio the villain played by Jake
Gyllenhaal well that's assuming that
spider-man is actually you know back
from the dead speaking of which
Avengers for the fourth Avengers film
at the end of Marvel's phase three when
it's released on May 3rd
which means you should get your tissues
ready with many of the contracts for
Marvel's biggest names expiring Avengers
4 will probably feature at least a few
major character deaths the permanent
kind this time if the studio continues
its no-holds-barred approach established
in infinity war Avengers 4 is sure to be
both completely epic and ridiculously
devastating ending several storylines
set up in past films while also getting
things ready for whatever's coming next
John wick three Parabellum Keanu Reeves
puppy loving hitman is coming back to
theaters on May 17th for John wick 3
Parabellum following the bloodbath of
the last movie wick is on the run with a
14 million dollar global contract on his
head lots of familiar faces are set to
return along with new additions like
Halle Berry as a mysterious affair the
third installment in the action-packed
insane assassin franchise features the
same writer-director team so if you love
all things wick expect more of the same
to come back the third time around I'm
dick you're not back it's chapter 2
penny wise the dancing clown will make
his terrifying return to the big screen
on September 6 the first film followed a
group of dangerously unsupervised kids
known as the losers club as they dealt
with an ancient evil being the sequel
will focus on those same kids 27 years
later now adults they return to Derry to
deal with the return of the child
chomping clown after the first film's
massive success it was easy to land
big-name stars to play the adult losers
including Jessica Chastain James McAvoy
and Bill Hader he is hoping they all
make it out alive
Wonder Woman 1984 when the woman is the
DCE used best performing film to date in
the u.s. so it makes sense that Warner
Brothers quickly ordered a sequel Wonder
Woman 1984 to out November 1st we'll
bring back director patty Jenkins who's
also co-writing the scripts while plot
details have been kept tightly under
wraps we know that when the woman 1984
found a way to bring back Chris Pines
beloved Steve Trevor the film will also
feature Kristen Wiig as a central body
cheetah and she's no stranger to playing
cat lady's
and I'm Veronica like Veronica but how a
cat would say it so look forward to more
action fun romance and bitter comic-book
rivalries Star Wars Episode nine there
have been some shake ups behind the
scenes of Star Wars Episode nine with
Lucasfilm dropping jurassic well
director Colin Trevorrow a few months
before production was set to begin good
thing they found someone who's
definitely qualified to take over the
force awakens JJ Abrams is returning to
write and direct the trilogy finale
throughout December 20th episode nines
plots are still a mystery but all the
expected major players are set to return
this embarrassing okay well all the
other major players but we can look
forward to Billy Dee Williams reprising
his role as fan favorites Lando
Calrissian the late Carrie Fisher will
also appear via unused footage from the
force awakens Joker and then there's the
wild card an else world style joke
origin movie starring the brilliantly
weird Joaquin Phoenix is now officially
for real with shooting scheduled to
start by the end of 2018
this reportedly darker and more
experimental take on mr. J is going to
be co-written and directed by the
hangovers Todd Phillips with the Clown
Prince of Crime expected to hit theaters
on October 4th 2019 Warner Brothers
describes the script as a gritty
character study but also a broader
cautionary tale sounds like it's no
laughing matter
[Music]